a convoy of truckers and their
supporters have been rolling through
highways across the country the group is
protesting a federal vaccine mandate
that came into effect january 15th and
it requires unvaccinated or partially
vaccinated truck drivers crossing the
canada u.s border to quarantine for 14
days now with more on this let's bring
in one of the truckers participating in
what's being dubbed the freedom convoy
or the freedom rally
that's harold jonker who's joining us
from fort erie this morning good morning
harold good morning candace thank you
very good thanks so much for joining us
so uh let's dive right in the truck
convoy has been dubbed the freedom rally
as we mentioned so what does that
exactly mean to you and why did you want
to participate
um i got involved with uh organizing the
uh the niagara
area um to um
yeah
stand up for our freedoms we've
over the last two years have been
dealing with a
pandemic and
it's now
been two years since they said two weeks
to flatten the curve and
i think uh canadians are saying we need
to
move on we need to
continue on in life and we need to
yeah end all mandates for sure so harold
we're hearing from politicians that 90
percent of truckers are vaccinated so
i'm just curious as to how this directly
affects you how does this quarantine
affect you
um
what it is is i've uh
i've been crossing the border for 22
years
and
my our company it has
20 some trucks that have been crossing
the border for 20
well about eight nine years and now all
of a sudden half the guys are sitting at
home and can't work so
it's gonna affect a lot of canadians
because about two million pounds are
gonna be
not able to uh
cross the border i'm getting a phone
call in so hopefully my my zoo my
camera's act is okay but okay so let me
jump ahead then while there has been a
lot of support we're seeing that in the
b-roll in all of this this movement is
gaining some negative attention as well
linked to
hateful online rhetoric so what's your
response to those concerned about
extremists veering into dangerous
territory and maybe kind of hijacking
what it is you hope to accomplish
well that's one thing we were very
conscious of
there's always with any protest there's
going to be some people that
are going to try to
make it something that it's not
and
but yeah we can't um
we can't uh
we can't control everybody but we can
control the message that's coming out
and and the message is that we aren't we
are not a violent group of people we're
a
group of people that are concerned
you've got families that are
supporting this it's it's unbelievable
how much
uh support we're getting and um we
didn't expect it to grow like this i'm
in fort erie and it's just unbelievable
we're leaving here shortly and
it's just unbelievable how
there's kids walking around here with
their with their mothers and uh so yeah
it's not it's not gonna go violent
that's for sure
okay well harold i know you're busy you
are on route as we can see but thank you
so much for taking the time to shed some
light on this for our viewers folks
that's harold jonker co-owner of jonker
trucking safe travels harold
thank you very much and thanks for
taking this time